hi and welcome to a very unusual video
considering my usual output of contents
it's also something which I totally
shouldn't have done because well I'm
already not finishing any of my series
and starting something new at the moment
is super impractical but to be honest I
couldn't stop myself from doing this so
yeah this is happening I am building a
skyscraper in planet coaster and it is
going to be a blueprints and I am doing
a commentary over this time-lapse just
like any of my other content would be
except the content at hand I guess is
very different from what I'm usually
doing in any case I hope you'll be able
to enjoy this regardless and hopefully
I'll actually be able to turn this into
a thing that's also going to be somewhat
successful so without further ado let's
get into the time-lapse so a little bit
of background because this isn't coming
out of the blue completely so I want to
introduce this a little bit more
basically I used to do this sort of
thing quite a bit in rollercoaster
second three and I'm also kind of
drawing some of the techniques from this
so for instance I am just going to make
one floor right now and I'm using the
pistol guy as a way to get the skill
rights so it is also going to be on
scale and once this floor is done I'll
basically be copying this over and over
again to build the tower itself and then
afterwards bring in all the unique
elements like maybe some slight
differences between the floors making a
roof and also making a foundation for
the tower itself so this is something
which I've really been drawing from
loroco second three and in the ways that
I've not only done this sort of
skyscraper building more in
rollercoaster than three but I'm also
using a sort of similar technique in
that sense and so even though this has
been barely done in planet coaster to my
knowledge I think I've seen a few people
try this but even most of the times when
it's done it's kind of in a theme park
context as well but in this case it's
really just the building itself it's not
even pretending to be a hotel for a
theme park or anything it's gonna be a
residential skyscraper meant for
any city or so I definitely want to
introduce the details of it a little bit
more but because of that whole roller
coaster country background I've really
just been wanting to try and build a sky
skyscraper in planet coaster at some
points and some of the things which have
just been holding me back is the fact
that I don't have much experience with
it in this game and we're really lacking
some glass pieces and this is really one
of the reasons why actually I've been
asking so much about glass pieces
because I've always wanted to try
something like this I just never figured
I could or should because there's no
glass in the game and at this point I've
just lost all of my Fox to give about
the facts and decided to try it anyway
so that's also why we're kind of here
and my whole interest with this in
general is also not completely out of
the blue i lurk a lot on skyscraper city
and like I like skyscrapers in general
or even modern architecture in general
it's just something which doesn't really
come out of my channel as much I think
because theme parks tend to be more
about architecture revivalism and try to
hark back to some older styles but I can
honestly appreciate modern architecture
just as much as I can or I should say
contemporary architecture to be
technically correct
I can appreciate contemporary
architecture just as much as old
architecture so honestly it's it's a bit
of an interest of mine that's never been
explored as much in my planet coaster
contents and then I want to bring out a
little bit more right now now
specifically the architecture of this
building is inspired by Rotterdam and
more specifically the Dutch posts 2000s
skyscraper architecture which is a lot
of the buildings a lot of the taller
buildings that you're seeing pop up in
the Netherlands right now because
traditionally until the end of the last
century the Netherlands hasn't really
been about building high whatsoever and
there were maybe just a few kind of
high-rise buildings but especially
recently a lot more high-rise buildings
have been appearing in Amsterdam and
Rotterdam and since I like to follow
these developments I suppose it's a
style that I've been influenced by quite
a lot
and I want to try and emulate a little
bit in planet coaster it's also
something which I think works out quite
well given the limitations of planet
coaster because obviously I need to find
a way to make something that kinda looks
like glass even though there is no
actual class in the game so I just took
a bluish color and gone I make it sound
really simple but looking for the
perfect shade of blue to make the leaf
book last was one of the most
time-consuming things that you didn't
see in this time-lapse but God that was
a struggle but um yeah I think this
architecture style works out quite well
because it makes it a little bit more
easy to hide that glass obviously it
would be really difficult to build glass
based condo towers like Toronto or
Vancouver where it becomes really
obvious that there's no good glass
texture the same goes for a lot of the
more modern glass towers like say the
Freedom Tower in New York or all of that
boxy glassy offers architecture maybe
even some of the stuff that you see in
the City of London since you need a good
glass texture in order to build a good
glass building but this kind of building
can look modern and appealing I think
while at the same time not depending so
much on glass and actually taking a lot
of influence from the look of the prefab
brick cladding which I'm using on this
building so I think overall it's just a
style which I know a lot about and which
is pretty doable in planet coaster so
that's why I decided to build this sort
of building and at this point I've
barely talked about the building itself
and my building process because things
have just been going way too fast as
life so it goes with the time-lapse I
suppose but at this point I'm also
adding some of this greenery because
that obviously just does make a building
look better I think set this before in
the past but it's it's probably very
relevant to say that in this video too a
lot of architects when they make their
renders of buildings that I give me a
tour to cities they tend to add a lot of
greenery because that just makes
everything look it's tiny bit better so
here I am just pretending that
realistically people will put palm trees
and lots of bushes on their balconies
which is just gonna make
building look better in hindsight's but
we'll get back to that later I think the
the placement of those planters is gonna
happen later at this point I was just
looking at my tower and thinking bit too
predictable I want to add some sort of
element that's off on the back not to
mention that there were windows all
around the building and I kindly wanted
to avoid doing that because there has to
be a space where people's bathrooms are
gonna be and so I figured we're kind of
over here might be a good space to have
not that many windows in just one little
sliver to let the light through and also
an element that kind of sticks out from
the rest of the building and makes this
side look a little bit more unique as
well so there we go just a little
element that adds a bit of detail and
more interesting shape into the rest of
the building okay by the way I need to
talk about one of my main inspirations
for this building because I didn't base
this building on any building in
particular it's just sort of got
influences from all around the place
but my major inspiration here was a
building called the shapes market story
actually no it's just scape marker story
in Rotterdam which is kind of similar in
look it's not very similar but sort of
but mostly in that it's a very slender
tall residential building with luxury
apartments so this would ideally be the
same maybe two apartments per floor and
so it's a very slender narrow building
that's really built in this kind of way
to provide all of the people living in
it with a good view of the city and a
sort of floor in which you have windows
and views all around which is something
that if you have the money to pay for
this kind of thing I'm pretty sure you
would enjoy quite a bit so that is
really the main inspiration for this
building but there is no building that
this is particularly modeled after maybe
there are some similarities to some
existing buildings on accidents but it's
basically my own little design now
moving to one of the things which is
gonna stick out a little bit because I
honestly
we always struggle with this kind of
thing I wanted to design a unique base
for the building in Dutch there's this
word called plinth which basically
refers to the bottom part of a building
that kind of connected the street level
and I've asked a charitable about this
from City skylines community and I think
we've both come to the conclusion that
for some reason there's not an English
translation of this word so I am not
entirely sure how to refer to this in a
good English way if anybody knows a word
that perfectly refers to the bottom
floors of a skyscraper that have a
different design from the rest of the
skyscraper and are made in a way to have
some sort of public facilities or
connection to street level at the bottom
of the tower if if anybody knows a word
in English for this I would be super
happy to know this but until that day I
honestly don't know exactly how to refer
to this so I'm just gonna call this the
base of the tower but as you can see the
bottom floors have a slightly different
design should be about 3 floors even
though this possibly looks like just one
with the third floor not really having
much in it I'm not exactly sure what it
would be used for maybe an office or so
and the bottom floor could be used for
either store or just an entrance lobby
whatever it is something that opens up
the street level a little bit more and
yeah makes it a little bit more of a
pleasant building to look at from the
ground and I know I said I struggle with
these kinds of things because I always
find it different I always find it
difficult to build a button for a tower
that has a different design from the
rest of the tower but still fits in the
same overall look and philosophy while
also being different at the same time so
it's it's kind of it's kind of difficult
to find the right balance between
different enough and having different
elements but at the same time having the
same characteristics come up that make
clear that it fits with the rest of the
building so for instance one of the
things which I try to do is get these
vertical black pillars back on the glass
at the bottom of the tower and make that
a a sort of design thing that comes from
the rest of the building and is the same
at the base
as it is with the rest of the tower
while at the same time adding this kind
of different elements with the two
horizontal lights big yeah the two
horizontal big white stripes that create
this sort of element that looks toward
the same direction as the little
triangular roof pipe looks toward to get
a slightly different sort of design
element at the bottom of the tower I'm
not entirely sure how much I like it I'm
quite happy with it but maybe it's a
little bit too different from the rest
of the building but overall I think it's
a pretty good pedestal for the rest of
the tower and something which looks a
little bit better on ground level than
just copying the rest of the tower over
until the ground so yeah that's
basically it for the building it's a
relatively short video since I'm just
working on one building and one
blueprints but in the end I am honestly
pretty happy with how it manages to look
I think it's a little bit better than my
expectations even you can definitely
tell that the glass is really fake and
really not real glass whatsoever still
wish that that was added into the game
although I do understand that there are
some performance issues with that I
honestly would not be able to give a
crap whatsoever about that because I
just wanna have glass but even still I
think it came out as a pretty realistic
looking residential building that
despite some of the limitations in the
game I would possibly see in real life
so yeah I'm pretty happy with this
overall I definitely want to try more of
these types of builds and let me know if
you're interested in this whatsoever if
there's somehow if in any crossover
between the planet Costa community and
the more wide City / urban interests
community but yeah that's been it for
this video thank you guys for watching
and I hope to see you guys in the next
skyscraper build
[Music]